the big news of the day of the month of
the year is that president trump
has been confirmed to have covered he
tweeted this news out
last night he tweeted out that he and
the
and the first lady have both been tested
positive for comedy he tweeted tonight
flotus and i tested positive for covert
19 we'll begin our quarantine and
recovery process immediately
we will get through this together and
you know naturally you
all the same people on twitter with the
blue check marks you would expect have
been just about as nasty as you would
expect
some people have not been some people
have been pretty classy about it we'll
get to that in a second
but the the white house doctor did
release a note
on this the white house doctor
acknowledging that the president has
come
come down with covet here is the letter
it says i release the following
information with the permission of
president trump and first lady melania
trump
this evening i received confirmation
that both president trump and first lady
melania trump have tested positive for
covid ii virus the president and first
lady are both well at this time they
plan to remain at home within the white
house during their convolescence
the white house medical team and i will
maintain a vigilant watch i appreciate
the support provided by some of our
country's greatest medical professions
and institutions rest assured i expect
the president to continue carrying out
his duties without disruption while
recovering i will keep you updated
on any future developments now obviously
we don't know the direction that covet
19 is going to take the president is 74
years old he is overweight which is a
complicating factor it is a pre-existing
condition it is an underlying condition
that can exacerbate the effect
of covet 19 so far it has been reported
that the
president of the united states has a
mild case or at least his symptoms
are mild we'll see how this plays
forward honestly i think from from
political point of view obviously
politics comes second so
our prayers go out to the trump family
just so they go out to any family that
is suffering with
covid 19 which can in fact be a very
serious
disease politically speaking this throws
a wrench into
a lot of what's going on because we have
a debate that is scheduled for about two
weeks from now presumably if the
president
goes through the process and then he
quarantines for 14 days he will get out
i believe literally the day of the
debate
to to do that debate so it throws a
wrench into that it obviously throws a
wrench into his campaign schedule he's
not going to be going out and doing
public events for quite a while because
he's supposed to according to the cdc
quarantined for 10 to 14 days we have to
see of course
the the vector that the disease is going
to take which direction the disease
is going to take here the political
fallout here is pretty obvious
for trump and the political fallout as
we'll see is
largely surrounding the severity of the
disease
if trump recovers from the disease
quickly if it turns out that this virus
is something that doesn't affect him
really badly and that in four or five
days
he's basically back to normal he has a
mild case then he's going to be able to
go out and he's going to say listen i
know that this thing
definitely affects some people truly
terribly and we have to protect those
people we have to make sure they get all
the care that they could possibly need
but the truth is that the vast majority
of cases tend to be rather mild and that
is true i mean statistically it is true
the vast majority of these cases tend to
be rather mild
virtually everyone below the age of 50
who gets this thing
recovers of it the death rates on this
thing are extraordinarily striated by
age if you're under the age of 20
then your likelihood of dying from covet
19 is something like
2 in 10 000 if you are above the age of
70 then your chances of dying of this
thing are something like 5
which is a lot higher obviously and
trump is in that
later that latter cohort so if he
recovers quickly and if he recovers
easily he's going to be able to
say with a certain amount of credibility
that it is important to recognize that
this disease does not affect everybody
equivalently
that many of these cases are mild and
it's important to keep that in mind when
we are talking
about recovery and the campaign probably
moves on obviously if it's much more
severe
then we don't just have a political
issue on our hands we have like an
actual human life issue
on our hands now it turns out a lot of
people
have been infected inside at the white
house apparently this thing started with
hope hicks is the
current supposition hope x of course is
a top aide to the president of the
united states other people who have
tested positive
at this point include ronald mcdaniel
which is a guest a little bit earlier on
the
show this week ronald mcdaniel the
chairwoman of the rnc according to the
new york times has tested positive for
covet and is experiencing mild symptoms
according to several people briefed on
the situation
ms mcdaniel is the latest person in
frequent contact with trump to test
positive
for the virus apparently she received
her diagnosis on wednesday and after a
crowded donor event in
march at mar-a-lago the president's
private club in florida miss mcdaniel
felt
ill but she tested negative way back
then of course trump is not the first
world leader to be infected prime
minister boris johnson of britain had a
very serious case i mean who's actually
hospitalized
president yaya bolsonaro of brazil
tested positive
as well bolsonaro's case was was much
milder
than johnson's case both of those men
are significantly younger than trump
he is older and probably at higher risk
just on a basic medical level
than either of those people it is true
that
a lot of people today are pointing out
you know trump's personal behavior we'll
get into that in
just a second and they're pointing out
that earlier this week
he seemed lethargic and that you know he
maybe should have taken precautions at
that point why i wasn't
tested at that point mike pence for for
what it's worth mike pence and the first
and the second lady
uh karen pence have both tested negative
for the virus
at this point and it is also true that
a lot of people get this thing and a lot
of people recover from this thing and a
lot of people get it under different
circumstances for example
justin trudeau's wife had this thing and
so
there's this sort of belief out there
this talismanic belief that if you do
all of the right things or if
what's what's even more bizarre if you
say all of the right things that you're
immune from the disease
and one of the things that's very
frustrating is people who watch this in
an attempt to be objective in any real
way about this is that there are certain
things you can do to minimize the
chances that you're going to get it
there's no guarantee you're not going to
get it because we're all living life
you're going to run into contact with
people n95 masks
may provide you a significant barrier
they may provide you
real protection but cloth masks don't
provide the same protection the original
idea of cloth masks was that mainly
you're preventing
other people from getting it not that it
prevents you from getting it
there was a point a month ago where
anthony faucet was suggesting this thing
is transmissible via the eyes
so he was suggesting that people
actually wear goggles if they could so
there's no guarantee
that you're not going to get it there
are things you can do to minimize it
we'll talk about whether trump has done
those things
but there's this belief on the left as
we'll see that
even more than any of that if you virtue
signal
about the virus this acts as some sort
of protection so trump's great sin here
was not even his personal behavior
it was the stuff that trump said if
trump had just said i'm super serious
about it over and over and over it would
have been fine
or if trump presumably had protested it
like a black lives matter rally
he wouldn't have gotten it or if he did
get it then it would have been worth it
because he would have been protesting
racism one of the big problems with this
entire debacle since march
is that where we should have been
following the science and being measured
in our language
about what works and what doesn't where
we should have pointed out
that risk factors vary by age where we
should have pointed out
that certain types of mass are better
than other types of mass and we should
have stopped this sort of virtue
signaling
about how if you wear a mask but it's
below your nose that's better than not
wearing a mask at all or something
or that if you wear a neck gaiter that's
i mean the cdc has said by the way a
negator is actually worse than nothing
a neck gator actually helps aerosolize
your spin like if you sneeze into a
negator it actually
blows it through the thing like a sieve
and then it just kind of
makes it go further it actually aerosols
it wider okay so
my big problem here is is twofold one i
think there's some legit criticisms to
be made of how trump
has personally in terms of his uh
attitude and what he's conveyed to other
people and his personal behavior has
handled coven
i also think that the media have set up
these bizarre standards where
you're immune to the disease if you're
protesting for racial justice
where if you run around and virtue
signal about wearing a mask 100 feet
from
other people this somehow makes you
immune to the disease
when it really has nothing to do with
any of that there's this sort of
talismanic worship of particular modes
of discussing
this disease that if you take it super
seriously then at least you're protected
from the backlash of the mockery if you
do get it
and again that is completely separated
from the public policy discussion
it's completely separated from a
rational scientific discussion of these
issues
so for example i've said on the show
many times that if you're my age if
you're 36 and you're
thank god healthy i'm 36 and i'm healthy
i don't have any underlying conditions
if i get this thing i'm not particularly
afraid of getting this thing because i'm
and i have no underlying conditions and
then i said it is also possible that i
could die of this thing if i get it
because it is possible that anybody
could die of this thing
if they get it although the chances are
extremely unlikely
now because i've said the former part
which is that statistically speaking i'm
extremely unlikely to die of this
disease
if god forbid something were to happen
to me then the media would jump on that
and suggest that i was taking it lightly
even though i specifically say
at the end of that sentence that it
could happen to me it's just very
unlikely that it's going to happen
to me people do not seem to understand
how statistics work in any real way so
if you say things like
trump has said before that not very many
people are dying of this thing
relative to the percentage of the
population at this point depending on
age
that may be statistically true it can
also be
it can also be insensitive but people
will use that as an example of trump not
taking the thing seriously as opposed to
is what he is saying actually true right
he said earlier that if you're young and
you get it you really are not at high
risk
that happens to be a true statement
that's not an example of him not taking
it seriously
and you saying that you are at high risk
if you're five as opposed to if you're
is actually being statistically
irresponsible with the information
but morally irresponsible right this is
sort of the divide that has happened is
that if you discuss this thing in a
statistically responsible way
then you are charged with being morally
irresponsible it's the aoc version of
reality
and if you say things that are
statistically irresponsible if you say
well yes it's true that older people get
it but if you're young you definitely
could die of it without any sort
of examination of the base rates or the
actual death rates the infection
fatality rate
then you are considered good and so if
something happens to you then we can say
well at least you took it seriously
right that was a good person
it's become a moral battle as much as it
has been a scientific battle
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button